لا مبضعه ولا مشرط هنا ولا وصفات طبيه
فالدكتور احمد الذي تخرج حديثا اضطر للعمل
في ورش لاصلاح الهواتف الذكيه ومعالجه
البرمجيات بسبب انحسار فرص التوظيف في
القطاع الصحي انا تخرجت في 2020
تحتاج زمن طويل لحد ما الواحد ينزل امتياز
او فتره تدريب
لازم الواحد كان يشوف بديل فنزلت في
مجال صيانه الهواتف الذكيه وشكله لسه
حواصل
بسبب الاجور الزهيده للاطباء يلخصوا هذا
المشهد المفارقه صارخه في السودان
ازدحام المرضى في المستشفيات في انتظار
طبيب يخففه عنهم معاناتهم
يقابله تكدس للاطباء امام بوابات التوظيف
وسط حظوظ ضئيله
لاستيعابهم
التخرج 6000 والسعه الاستيعابيه 4000 يعني
معناته بيكون عندك الفين انتظار لمده عام
او لعامين اسعافيا الحاجه اللي عملناها
وسعنا التدريب في بعدد من المستشفيات
التدريب التخصص على سبيل المثال تم حديث
مع القطاع الخاص توسيع التدريب في بعض
المؤسسات القطاع الخاص لو بعد التخصصات
تخرج الجامعات السودانيه ما يصل الى 7000
الطبيب سنويا مقابل خمسه الاف وظيفه فقط
كما يرفد مجلس التخصصات الطبيه النظام
الصحي في البلاد باكثر من 60 تخصصا سنويا
تضيق بهم المرافق الصحيه ورغم هذا العدد
الكبير من الاطباء الا ان مستشفيات
السودان تعاني نقصا كبيرا في الكوادر
الصحيه
المشكله كانت تعتمد على وجود وظائف تخصصها
وزاره الماليه لتدريب اطباء الامتياز
واداره الصحه ليس بالضروره ان تمنع اطباء
الامتياز رواتب خاصه غير الراغبين في ذلك
الراغبين في اختصار ان تسمح بها ان تسمح
بالتدريب على نفقه الطالب
ضيقوا فرص التدريب والتعيين يبدو السبب
الرئيسي الا ان تدهور الاوضاع في
المستشفيات بولايات السودان مختلفه جعل
الاطباء يفضلون التوزيع داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم مما زاد من درجه اختناق الوظيفي
هؤلاء الاطباء لربما كانوا من المحظوظين
في ايجاد فرص للتدريب بعد التخرج لكن
اخرين غيرهم هاجروا او هاجر المهنه لا
لكثره الاطباء ولكن بسبب ضيق فرص العمل في
المرافق الصحيه الطاهر المرضي الجزيره
الخرطوم